My name is Aah and I am 23 years old.
I'm a Quranic studies student from
Bandum. Uh marriage is my question is
marriage is one of the ways Islam builds
brotherhood and community. But due the
many uh do but due to the many marriage
relate incident happening in Indonesia,
many in my generation have come to say
marriage is scary.
>> Uh marriage is
>> scary.
>> Scary.
>> Yeah. How can we fix this mindset and
revive the true spirit of marriage as a
path to Islamic peace and brotherhood?
Thank you
>> sisters. asked the question that in
Indonesia marrying is scary. So how can
you fix this problem? Our beloved
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
marriage completes half your deen.
Marriage completes half your deen. So
one brother asked me in the
questionnaire session that if I marriage
twice then will I complete my full dean?
This is not what the prophet meant. The
prophet meant if you marry only if you
marry can you become a mother or father.
Only if you marry can you become husband
or wife. These are important duties in
Islam. Duty of a husband, duty of a
wife, duty of a father, duty of a
mother. So only if you married do you
have an opportunity to fulfill the
duties. Therefore the prophet said
marriage completes half your deed. So
now because of the situation your
question that marriage is scary is
because now the world is changing. Many
people you know they want dowi
they want lifestyle. So if I marry I
want so much money someone may want
someone may not want someone may demand
certain things. So I do know that
because of certain society
people because of the wrong demands
marriage may become scary. You know what
did the prophet say? Make marriage so
easy that zena becomes difficult.
Now for marriage oh you require minimum
maybe maybe 10 million rup 100 million
rupe otherise you can't marry or maybe I
don't know what the rupia how rupia is
different maybe you require 1 billion to
get married otherwise you can't get
married and zena is so easy you give
little money and you zina so prophet
said make
nikah easy zena will become difficult a
prophet said in a hadith that when you
marry you look for four criteria any
human being looks for four criter
criteria one is wealth, beauty,
nobility and virtue dean and the most
important is virtue. So normally when
people marry they look for beauty, they
look for wealth, they look for nobility,
lineage and they look for virtue dean.
The prophet said the most important is
so if you marry looking at the spouse
he's religious then your marriage will
be successful.
If you look at other things, I want to
marry a beautiful girl. Okay, the beauty
will last for how long?
Wealth, will the wealth take you to
Jenna? Nobility, will it take? So the
prophet said the most important is
virtue. So if you marry, okay, I want to
marry a boy who's virtuous, who knows
the Quran, who has good class, he'll
take care of you. If he's marrying you
for your beauty,
how long will the beauty last? So
therefore, the prophet said the most
important is dean.
It is religion. It is virtue. So if your
Indonesian society goes back to the
hadith of the prophet that we should
look for spouse who are religious,
you'll find whole Indonesia becoming
more religious. Now it is but may not be
that level. You you'll find more
Indonesians becoming more religious and
the whole society would become better
and people would love to marry not say
that marry marrying is scary. In fact,
Allah says in the Quran in surah room
30:21 that Allah has put love and mercy
between the hearts of the man and the
woman. Allah says in Bakar 2 verse 187
that they are your garments and you are
their garment. The wife is the garment
of the husband and the husband is the
garment of the wife. So if you follow
the guidelines of the Quran and if both
are Islamic
you difficult for you to live without
them
you understand I find difficult to live
without my wife and my wife had come
with me but she wasn't feeling well so
she had to go back to Malaysia she gave
talks in Jakarta
she's a D I'm also D myself my
so if you have a good wife or if you
have a good husband you would love to be
together.
Life
it's it's a pathway to Jenna. It's not
scary. Hope that answers the question.